Good morning!
It's time for school.
Grab your school bag and hurry up.
The school bus is coming to pick us up.
Do you see it?
What color is it?
Yes, it's yellow.
Do you know why school buses are yellow?
Yellow gets your attention faster than any other color.
People notice yellow objects first.
That's why they are yellow.
Wow, there are lots of seats on our bus.
The kids are excited for school.
Sometimes we sing on the bus.
What do you like to do on a school bus?
Oh, look at the red stop sign on the bus.
It is telling other cars to stop for the kids to get on the bus.
Our bus driver is very friendly.
He picks us up at the same time every day.
He drops us off, too.
Let's get on the bus!